So,
uh,
what do you got it from me?
So we were going to talk about,
yeah,
the uh,
I was wearing,
she told you because we talked last time about my book about depression,
loss conditions and when things,
it was just as to me as we talk about the book I wrote about addiction and the
war on drugs and really was that out last time you a book that came up for your
sports,
just kind of in a new edition where there's loads of extra material particular
about the opiate crisis and essentially cause so you added to it.
Yeah,
loads of new stuff because the epics about five years old now and um,
although with loads of new stuff now,
but you know,
it was something I cared about for this really like personal reason that one of
my earliest memories is of trying to wake up one of my relatives and not,
not being able to,
I didn't,
I didn't understand why then because it was little boy.
But as I got older,
I realized we had drug addiction in my family.
And it goes to the point where I was writing,
chasing the scream,
my book about the drug war,
about,
I guess I started eight years ago and some of the people I love,
we're in a really shitty condition,
terrible state.
And I was trying to figure out what to do.
Nothing I was doing was working.
I think I was doing,
was helping.
And I decided,
right,
okay,
well there are lots of people all over the world are trying to deal with this
problem.
I want to go and meet with them,
talk with them.
So I ended up going on this big journey.
It took three years.
I traveled over 30,000 miles.
I wanted to sit with,
um,
you know,
people who'd been through addiction actually led to a lot of other aspects of
the war on drugs.
It doesn't count as important as the,
what we do about addiction.
Um,
I don't want to sit with the places that had the harshest possible policies.
Like we mentioned,
Arizona where I went out with this,
these women were made to go out on chain gangs and they're humiliated and,
and,
and tormented Vietnam where they make people with addiction problems go into
literally forced labor camps and the places that had the most compassionate
possible policies like Portugal where they decriminalized all drugs when
incredible results.
Switzerland where they legalized heroin,
Um,
and I guess I ended up just spending so much time.
It's such a crazy mixture of people from a transgendered crack dealer in
Brooklyn who ended up actually being one of the smartest people I know to a hit
man for the deadliest Mexican drug cartel who's definitely not one of the
smartest people I know.
And I learned loads of things.
But I guess the heart of what I learned is just so much of what we've been told
about this for so long.
It's now 100 years since we started fighting the war on drugs in this country
and it was then imposed on the rest of the world.
So much of what we're told is wrong.
Drugs aren't what we think they are.
Addiction isn't what we think is the war on drugs isn't what we think it is.
And the alternatives to the war on drugs aren't what we think they are.
So in some ways it's kind of daunting to Rick go all over the world and realize
so much of what we take for granted isn't right.
But that opens up this whole exciting other set of possibilities.
The main reason why people assumed that people do drugs just to escape reality.
Um,
what do you think is the primary thing that they're running from?
So you've got to separate out two things.
And this surprised me cause my family's experience was pretty bad and
catastrophic addiction.
But most drug use,
even the main drug war body in the world,
the UN Office of drug control admits that 90% of all currently banned drug use
is what they call non problematic.
So the person isn't addicted and it doesn't damage their health,
right?
So 90% so let's set that aside.
We'll come back to that.
Okay.
There's like 90% that's recreational use where people use because it makes their
lives better.
Then you've got the 10 coffee sip of wine or,
or uh,
oh boy,
NRC or a whole range of a whole range of currently cannabis,
a whole range of currently illegal drugs.
Um,
in most cases there are some people who have addictions to cannabis,
but you said that you don't got,
got to ask,
well what's happening with this 10% who have got a problem?
Right?
What's going on?
And one of the things that really blew my mind in the research for chasing the
scream was realizing I had deeply misunderstood what addiction is.
I had misunderstood the thing I thought I had been seeing in front of me since I
was a kid.
Right?
So most people,
let's think about heroin addiction because it was close to me.
Most people,
if we stop the next 20 people to walk past your,
you know,
your,
your studio.
And we said to them,
what Causes Heroin Addiction?
I think they'd look at us like we were stupid.
And they'd say,
well,
the clue's in the name dip shit,
right?
Heroin causes her.
In addition,
we've been told this story for a hundred years.
It's become totally part of our,
our common sense,
right?
We think if we took the,
we took the next 20 people after that,
he walked past the studio and we injected them all with heroin everyday for a
month.
At the end of that month,
they'd all be heroin addicts for simple reason.
There's chemical hooks in heroin that their bodies would start to desperately
physically need.
Um,
and we think that a lot of people think that's what addiction is,
right?
It's this physical hunger for the chemical hook inside the drug,
Um,
there is some reality to chemical hooks.
They exist.
They're real,
but that's actually a very small part of what's going on.
The first thing that alerted me to the fact there's something wrong with that
story we've been told is when it was explained to me by loads of doctors in
Britain,
where I'm from,
if you step out into the street and you get hit by a truck and you break your
hip,
you'll be taken to hospital and you'll be given loads of a drug called
diamorphine.
Diamorphine is heroin,
right?
It's the medical name,
Vera minutes.
The stuff you'll be given in a hospital is much better than the shit you buy on
the street because it's medically pure,
it's not contaminated.
And if what we think about addiction is right,
that it's just caused by exposure to the drug,
what should be happening to all these people in British hospitals who have been
given loads of heroin,
right?
Anyone watching this podcast,
he's got a British grandmother who's had a hip replacement operation.
Your grandmother's taken a shit ton of heroin,
right?
And if what we think is right,
the addiction is caused primarily by exposure to the chemical hooks,
lines of these people should believe in hospital and trying to score on the
streets,
right?
This has been studied very Catholic.
Virtually never happens,
right?
And when I learned that,
it just seems so weird to me.
I thought it couldn't possibly be true,
right?
How could it be?
You've got someone in a hospital bed who's taking loads of really potent heroin.
They don't become addicted.
And in the alleyway outside,
you've got someone who's using a actually a weaker form of the drug who becomes
addicted.
How can,
how can that be?
What's happening here?
And I only began to understand it when I,
when I went to Vancouver and met this amazing man could professor Bruce
Alexander who did an experiment that's really transformed how we think about
addiction all over the world.
It's led to a new way of thinking and loads of new evidence.
So professor Alexander explained to me this story that we'd been told,
right?
The addiction is caused by the chemical hooks primarily comes from a series of
experiments that were done earlier in the 20th century.
They're really simple experiments.
Your viewers can try them at home if they're feeling a little bit shitty today,
right?
You take a rat,
you put it in a cage and you give it two water bottles.
One is just water and the other is water laced with either heroin or cocaine.
You might remember in the 1980s there's a famous partnership for drug free
America ad that's,
that shows this experiment,
right?
And the rat in this cage starts to drink.
The PF always prefers the heroin water and almost always kills itself within a
week or two,
right?
So there you go.
That's,
that's our story.
The,
you're exposed to the drug,
it takes you over and then you just die,
right?
But in the 70s professor Alexander comes along and says,
he was working with people with addiction problems and he's like,
well,
hang on a minute.
We put these rats alone in an empty cage.
They've got nothing that makes life meaningful for rats,
right?
What would happen if we did this differently?
So he built a cage that he called rat park,
which is basically like heaven Veracyte's,
right?
They've got loads of friends.
They've got as a cheese,
they got as a colored balls,
they can have loads of sex.
Anything arap finds meaningful in life is there in rat park.
And they've got both the water bottles,
the normal water and the drug water.
And of course they try both.
They don't know what's in them.
This is the fascinating thing in rat park,
they don't like the Waterbury much.
None of them ever use it compulsively.
The heroin,
the heroin,
water,
none of them ever use it compulsively.
None of them have overdose.
So you go from almost 100% compulsive use and death by overdose when their lives
are shitty to none.
When they have the things that make life meaningful and has loads of human
examples.
I'm sure we'll,
we'll we'll talk about,
but the,
the main thing I took from this is that the opposite of addiction is not
sobriety.
The opposite of addiction is connection.
We have to ask ourselves what are the contexts in which people become addicted?
Because there are some contexts where people find these drugs extremely
addictive and there are some context where they don't become addicted at all.
There's something,
the drug plays a role.
Chemical Hooks are real.
I can talk about how we know that they play some role,
but they're actually a surprisingly small role of what's going on.
Small amount of what's going on.
We know this from,
I mean there's so many examples,
but could you give me another one in at the same time as rat park,
there was an experiment going on that everyone listens to this repetitive,
the Vietnam War,
right?
In Vietnam,
shitloads of American troops were using heroin,
right?
It was very easy to get it out of there.
They'd actually insanely,
they had cracked down on cannabis and so people would move to heroin because
sniffer dogs can't detect,
um,
heroin disease lays cannabis.
So calories was everywhere.
Sorry.
Uh,
heroin is everywhere.
Loads of American troops were using it.
And if you look at what people said at the time,
the authorities,
the Nixon White House,
they were shitting themselves cause they're like,
they believe this chemical hooks theory of addiction.
So they're like,
fuck,
when this Warren's,
we can have,
you know,
half a million heroin addicts on the streets of the United States.
There's a really good study that followed these,
these men home and it found that the vast majority of them just stopped,
right?
They didn't go into then go to rehab.
Most of them that didn't go into horrific withdrawal.
Some of them had an uncomfortable flu like symptoms,
but most of them just stop.
Now,
if you believe this old theory that chemical hooks take you over,
that makes no sense.
But if you understand what professor Alexander is saying and that all the new
evidence about addiction that I go through and chasing the scream,
it makes it makes perfect sense,
right?
You,
me,
everyone in this area,
if I took any of us and put us in a horrific pestilential jungle where we don't
want to be,
and I made you kill a load of people and potentially die at any moment,
you would find heroin much more appealing than you do now,
right?
If we want to understand why people turn to painkillers,
we've got to understand why they're in pain,
right?
Um,
and,
and the,
the core of addiction it's made me,
I learned from these amazing experts all over the world,
the,
the core of addiction.
It's about not wanting to be present in your life because your life is too
painful,
a place to be.
And once you understand that,
you can see why what we've been doing is such a disaster,
right?
Cause the theory we have with the war on drugs.
Think about Arizona.
We can talk about that more,
but I,
you know,
like I say,
I went to this nightmare prison it Estrella prison in,
in Phoenix,
Arizona,
where people are humiliated.
And the theory behind that,
part of the theory behind the war on drugs is if you've got people who are
addicted,
you got to inflict pain on them to,
you know,
give them an incentive to stop,
right?
But once you understand that pain is in fact the fuel of addiction is in fact
the primary cause of addiction.
You can see why sometimes people say that doesn't work.
Truth is much worse.
Right?
That makes addiction worse.
Those women I went out with and spent all that time with who were,
you know,
humiliate.
I remember in that prison,
we come back from being on the chain gang where they have to,
sometimes they have to dig graves.
They weren't doing that the day I was there.
They had to collect garbage the day I was one of the days I was there.
But we come back and normally with prisons as a journalist,
they don't want to show you anything,
right?
You're like,
you have to kind of really finagle to get them to show you anything in this
prison.
Um,
it's like a pantomime of cruelty.
They wanna show it to you.
The whole point is to humiliate these people,
right?
So the women I've been talking to in the men were really terrified of what they
called the whole right is the solitary blog.
And so I said to the gods,
will you show me the whole,
I'm sure they say no.
They're like,
yeah,
sure.
Come on Australia.
So go around to the whole,
and these women who put up the most like trivial infractions,
like having a cigarette is literally a hole,
right?
It's like a concrete block.
You're on your own.
There's nothing in it.
There's a tiny window where you can see sunlight,
no TV,
nothing.
Um,
and I remember speaking to a woman who was in this and suddenly thinking,
this is the closest you could get to an exact human recreation of the cages that
guaranteed addiction in rats.
Right?
And this is what we're doing,
thinking it will stop these women being addicted.
It's that the system we've built,
a doctor,
Gabor Martay,
an amazing guy said to me,
you know,
if negative consequences stopped addiction,
there won't be a single addict in the world.
Ryan,
what have people with addiction problems not suffered?
What humiliation have they not endured?
So we've got this,
I think we've got to really shift a perspective on what addiction is.
And there are places that have done this that have led to incredible results.
The,
I love that rat experiment one because that had always been parodied as this is
the proof positive that these drugs are so terrible for you.
But once they figured out that if you take those rats and put them in a
wonderful place and they don't have addiction,
it really does make you step back and go,
okay,
what is exactly going on here?
Obviously there's chemical hooks.
They are real like people that are on sustained prolonged use of opiates,
especially people with back injuries have an incredibly difficult time kicking
them,
even really positive people who don't necessarily have awful lives.
But,
um,
it's,
it's one of those things that gets in your head and then you sort of,
it,
you,
you've,
you've heard it,
you repeat it.
But it's the reason why I asked you the question.
It's like,
what,
what is,
what is the cause for most people,
you believe it's,
uh,
an unfulfilled life or a painful life or painful self image or remorse for your
past?
Or like what is it that,
do we have like primary reasons or primary attributes that we attach to these
people that are drug?
Yeah,
so this was what my more recent book,
which is called loss connections,
uncovering the real causes of depression and the unexpected solutions is,
is about,
cause I think the core of addiction is,
it's about trying to deal with pain,
right?
But the causes of human pain are obviously huge.
But what I learned is the scientific evidence for nine causes a kind of deep
despair right now.
If you think about depression and it's very similar factors play out with
addiction,
they're actually densely interconnected,
um,
uh,
phenomena.
But,
um,
there are real biological factors,
right?
Your genes can make you more vulnerable to that.
Just like some people find it easier to put on weight than others.
Um,
and there are real brain changes that happen when you become depressed or
addicted.
That can make it harder to get out.
Right?
But at most of the factors that are causing this,
despair are not factors in our biology.
There factors in the way we live.
I think it's a kind of,
this doesn't cover all of the causes that I learned about Veloce connections,
but it comes a lot of them.
Everyone watching your show knows they have natural physical needs,
obviously,
right?
You need food,
you need water,
you need shelter,
you need cleaner.
Exactly.
If I took those things away from you,
you'd fucked pretty quickly.
Right?
But there's equally strong evidence.
The all human beings have natural psychological needs,
right?
You need to feel,
you belong.
You need to fill.
Your life has meaning and purpose.
You need to feel that people see you and value you.
You need to be,
you've got a future that makes sense.
And this culture we've built is good at lots of things,
and I'm really glad to be alive today for all sorts of reasons.
Had to go to the dentist the other day.
I'm glad to be alive now,
not like a hundred years ago,
but there's a lot of evidence that we've been getting less and less good at
meeting these deep underlying psychology.